welcome to another episode of not too
deep i'm your host grace helbig and i
am desperately trying to contain my
excitement
about this episode finally it happened
the one and only michael buckley is my
guest today and
if you know who he is you know that he's
a very special person in my life
and so many of your lives at the very
beginning of youtube he's an og youtuber
he is a fast-talking sassy gay
uh gunko uh and now
youtuber turned life coach his whole
journey through
the world of new media is wonderful it
started as a public access
television show that he created himself
and now he lives in his twin sister's
basement
and his life coaching and living his
absolute best most fulfilling most
purposeful life it's
uh he uses excitement he uses
uh advice and just a vibrancy
that is so pure and wonderful i hope
hope hope you enjoyed this episode
as much as i did here's michael buckley
on not too deep
[Music]
uh i'm so glad i got michael buckley in
between
his um furious tweeting at our current
president of the united states
so thank you oh my god like i literally
wasn't on twitter for years and i
thought i'll come back
you know this is what i'll do with my
time oh
but i love it it's like one of my new
favorite things to watch because
twitter to me is helpful and is also
obviously like a dumpster fire at the
same time and so it's hard to like sift
through and want to see what's happening
but then not want to see everything
that's happening
and i like that your tweets are
constructive
like they're a little sassy but they're
also constructive for the president
thank you i took a strengths assessment
and my number one
strength was humor my number three
strength was perspective
so i'm always trying to use humor and
perspective
and now the president doesn't have any
self-awareness and i'm sure he doesn't
read tweet replies
and fun fact i actually have him muted
but yes
it's like looking up your ex-boyfriend
on facebook we're not friends but i want
to know
so i've muted you but i've died to know
what weird stuff you're tweeting today
leader of the free world oh man did you
ever think you'd be here
in 2020 spending your time doing that
i knew it was all gonna shake out like
this and it's funny because i made a
video on the youtube.com in 2006
and the title was donald trump is an
[ __ ] and so i'm like
i knew we'd be here someday you
manifested a lot of things apparently i
did i did i did
i love 20 20. uh i mean it's
i love that you have found the ability
to love it
the uh cause what else are you gonna do
you're just gonna
like waste your energy hating something
you can't change
necessarily it's terrible and it's
ridiculous and it's a dumpster fire
or it's a beautiful growth opportunity
so it's so funny when i'm working with
people they show up and they want to
work on stuff
and it's like in 2020 we had
back-to-back
back-to-back growth opportunities
whether we wanted them or not
here's cobin which totally resets our
reference points
and gives us an opportunity to grow and
then just when we kind of get used to
comed here's racism and
so it's like coven racism donald trump
it's it's whether we and if we're not
growing and evolving this
is terrible and we're waiting for this
to be over and to be solved
and so i'm really focusing on all the
lessons i'm going to learn this year and
all the wonderful takeaways i'm going to
have
on the other side of this well that's
really beautiful and i think that you
have a lot of experience in growing and
changing
more than a lot of other people on that
note
let's start back at the beginning of of
your public access
television show which was what i learned
the impetus for your youtube channel no
yes so in may of 2005 i slept on down to
wallingford public access channel with
18 hours worth of cue cards and i just
started
talking about local government i'd make
fun of the mayor
if somebody got a offense i'd be like
shout out to the smiths they got a
permit for offense
i would read the police i would read the
police squad or like i was insane
so i would and then i would do celebrity
news and so right
that segment kind of became what the
bucks show which was a five minute rant
about celebrities
in the middle of my public access show
wow so you've always been interested in
the world around you you've always been
interested in like people doing things
and what they're doing
totally and i'm always looking for the
humor so i remember it was funny because
i used to watch reality shows like the
real world
or survivor or american idol season one
and i would take i would literally have
a pad like this and i would write down
jokes there was nothing to tweet there
was no
youtube but i would write jokes thinking
i'm gonna go to work tomorrow and drop
some kelly clarkson jokes
oh lucky lucky for me steve and you know
what's his name put together youtube so
i could thrive
and share my terrible jokes with
millions of people
dozens now i mean okay
so you have this public access tv show
which is just so funny to me
that you did that and sought that out
and like
made it your own that's incredible like
you're
a true like renaissance man using the
resources at your fingertips that you
had
and then you get on youtube and then
what the buck show
blows up in like what 2007 8
9 yeah 2007 like my first hit video was
like november 2006. so i was pretty
pretty popular pretty early like i
definitely put it i had a year's worth
of content before anybody really saw me
and then i had one video get like 200
000 views and that's kind of when my
adrenaline hit in and i was like
i don't know how many people are tuning
in in wallingford connecticut
but 200 000 people across the globe are
watching me
make horrible jokes about beyonce and
jennifer hudson
and so yeah so that's when in 2007
i started doing it five days a week and
then yeah then the partnership program
and then
life and that retirement and
yeah well so so you're doing it in 2007
and the partnership program happens and
that for people that don't
know what that is that's basically how
would you describe it because i
it's like youtube created uh like a
they offered to pay the creators
basically like if you reached a certain
number of views i forget exactly how it
worked
do you remember at that point yeah so up
until like that point we were all just
dumping content on the internet
and no making no thought that you could
monetize it that just sounded ridiculous
and so in the summer of 2007 youtube
hand-picked like 40 people and said
we're gonna share revenue
with you and it was like a 50 50 split
or a 40 60 split
or whatever and i just remember getting
the email from george strompolis who
then
started full screen and was you know
very big in the space in the beginning
and i remember crying i remember being
like oh my god my life is gonna
change fast forward to two months later
when i got my first check for like a
hundred dollars
and i was like oh well i've gotten
millions of views and i've made a
hundred dollars don't give up your day
job
prank good night so yeah but that
partnership program started very small
and then i remember like two years later
suddenly everybody being a partner and
being like but i was so special
i
people don't know what we're talking
about but it felt like such a big deal
to get a banner and then email someone
on my face to be like can you make a
banner for me
yes i remember trying to figure out like
a very crude
like ms paint or something to make
myself something
it was and then you asked people to put
you in their sub boxes
because that was the way to to market
yourself
and so when you're doing this did you
because it was still lost on me in the
beginning years of youtube probably
because i was working for another
company that like owned all my content
but it
the idea of it being a business was
still kind of i feel like i was really
slow to pick up on that did you
kind of set your eyes on that once you
saw numbers coming in and like
understood and like realized the
business part of it
i understood it pretty quickly because i
remember
after like four months of not much money
then youtube changed the way the ads
made and suddenly i was making like ten
thousand dollars a month
and that was way more than i was making
at my day job
and then i really did reach out to
people i remember reaching out
to um like the cw and just asking to
promote their stuff and they were paying
me like three thousand dollars a pop to
promote stuff
i remember reaching out to i remember
reaching out to sony and just saying i
love your content you have no views do
you want to work with me
and they would pay me to promote stuff
so i definitely was and again i was a
grown-up
so there was something different between
me and like 17 year olds
who were like i want them all to think
i'm their best friend
i would hate for anybody to think that i
was making money off of this
so i definitely enjoyed the money and
went for the money
and i remember talking to you around
2012
and asking you specifically about a
brand deal and you told me like how much
you made
and i was like oh they should have paid
you like 10 times that yeah
yeah i was truly in it for the content
sake as long as i could like pay my rent
i was doing okay and
yeah you and hannah hart uh both really
grilled me on
being uh stronger and having a bigger
backbone when it came to the business
side of things
but the okay so how long would you
consider like yourself actually like
truly active in the youtube space
so i like to look at it like i feel like
i was active 2006 to around 2016
like full time and i always think of my
career like i
loved it for like i loved it
unconditionally until around 2011. so i
had about five great years
and then i started to fall apart
mentally and i really wasn't enjoying
the content i was making
so then i had about three years of just
struggle busting still making content
but really not enjoying it
and then in 2016 i decided to retire
what the buck show
i wasn't getting any views i wasn't
making any money i was playing a
character i had created for public
access
10 years ago and so it was it was
time to go do something else with my
life but i did spend the next
two years or so still making videos
occasionally still getting some
sponsorship so wanting to maintain my
youtube persona in case anybody wanted
to throw a couple thousand dollars at me
here and there
um but yeah but now i am officially
retired and have no
interest in creating content on youtube
i
i find that so inspiring did you have
i mean could you say like it took three
years of you know half-heartedly
making things did you do you remember
was there like an
aha epiphany moment that you were
retiring the show or was it just kind of
uh built up over time of gradually like
just not finding the fun in it anymore
yeah like it had built up over time and
i mean it was the longest i had ever
done anything like i had worked with
autistic children for seven
years i was in an executive assistant
office role for six or seven years
and then being a youtuber was such a
goofy career and again now i'm a life
coach i could have kept my head in the
game i could have coached myself to
success
i could have figured it out i didn't
want to figure it out
i had outdone myself and i mean honestly
i could see myself in 10 years being
like i'll make content again but at this
point in my life my life is so
satisfying and different and happily
removed from it
like even if i make a video now it's
like here's a video but i'm just
it's not what i'm doing it's like it's
like i look at youtube the way i look at
playing soccer it's just something i do
but it had taken over so much of my life
and that's the thing too like we were
the first generation of youtubers
so it's like a teacher knows you're
going to get your summers off and after
knows the role is over it's time to go
to a sitcom
as a youtuber you don't really have
clear boundaries
and expectations and again really it is
financial too so it's like if i make 20k
a month and then the next month i make
2k i'm like
do i want to even be doing this and then
i find there's a loneliness and it's
it's
and i see creators and i can just see it
in their eyes i'm like
i never had that many friends and so
suddenly to have a million
subscribers or thousands of comments it
did give me dopamine
and it did give me joy but it also now
when
i have so many real life friends i like
oh that's so
different than what i did you know
totally yeah
but that's why i think your story is so
important and so helpful to
i think myself and a lot of other people
like you said you can see it in people's
eyes you can
tell you can read between the lines like
you can really
get a vibe from someone the same way you
can get a vibe from someone that makes
them popular and that's why you like
them
you can also get a vibe that like
something's off with this person
and to be i think a lot of people
struggle with the ability
to finally truly walk away from it like
you said because there's no boundaries
so we have to create it for ourselves
we have to make the individual decision
to say i've gotten what i
need out of this and i can walk away for
you to find
life coaching after youtube was that
did you know that that's kind of where
you wanted to go or was that sort of
like
like reaching in the dark for something
and you found life coaching
yeah i mean it's kind of two things
number one i bought a book about life
coaching in 1999 and it's such a goofy
feel like it's a joke on a sitcom you
watch roseanne
and aunt jack he's a life coach or
alison
a person who doesn't have their life
together you're a life coach
it's like when you see your friends on
facebook who are therapists and you're
like why do you seem like the messiest
[ __ ] here or you're a goddamn therapist
but anyway that's another that's another
story but so i bought this book about
life coaching and i was like this is fun
this is cool this is positive psychology
which i'm very interested in and
well-being and emotional health and
gratitude and all that stuff but it i
then i just forgot about it i put the
book away
and then so that's my first introduction
to life coaching um and then in 2015
when life wasn't going well i did hire a
life coach and five minutes later i was
like oh i get it
so it was it was so lovely because i had
gone to therapy and rambled and got no
offense
i didn't need therapy i didn't i didn't
need to go a deep dive into therapy
i just needed a life coach to kind of
give me some direction and some
questions and some perspective
and i really and i say this all the time
the moment i realized that i was the
problem and i was the solution
i was flooded with self-confidence for
the rest of my life
because until that point youtube had
caused me a lot of problems or my
ex-husband and it caused me a lot of
problems or
and i think of all the dumb i see people
now tweeting about youtube i'm like go
you suppose you nothing youtube owes you
nothing youtube i promise you go
get a job um you know or
love it you love it or you get the hell
out of there you know
you know it's a guy that's the thing
like you see people on twitch for 12
hours i don't want to get a job
go get a job it's okay i know i feel
like it's just
uh you've become one of the audience
members on like jerry springer that's
like go get a job
yeah i mean i promise it's good on the
other side
um but yeah so i mean i think life i'm
the product of life coaching and so
that's everything like i know people who
reach out to me and life's not going
well they're like maybe i'll be a life
coach or i talk to a youtuber like i
give advice on my channel
i should be a life coach but that's not
what i'm doing but okay like yes it's
lovely that these teenagers
look to you for advice and you're like
maybe again
it's not for me it is my great life
passion and my great
life fulfillment and so that's it like
that i
i fell into it by purpose but i've
always wanted this
so i love that i love that it's great
and it's just really great to
watch you find your purpose that isn't
connected to youtube
like you're saying like they owe you
nothing and it's okay to walk away and i
feel like that's
the thing that a lot of people are
struggling with right now is the idea of
walking away and not knowing
how else they could get fulfillment in
another area
of their life and so i think it's really
important for you to be like sending
that message
because i've been talking about this a
lot with everyone like we're the first
wave of people that have been doing
youtube
like this so there's no real studies on
the effects of it
uh on our psychology the way that like
we have
we can study like you know child actors
and things like that
that i think there's gonna be a lot of
really interesting effects
on different types of people from
being so heavily involved in this
platform for so long
and i think it's really great to see
people like you evolve out of it
and succeed uh outside of it but still
be able to like
and i love it i love it i have no
complaints you will i
have i've written blogs about i have
nothing but gratitude i have a tattoo of
a youtube logo
i i have great i love my ex-husband it
doesn't mean i want to be married to him
anymore
i love youtube it doesn't mean i want to
be a famous content creator anymore
there's nothing but joy and gratitude
when i see creators who are after me
tweeting weird things about youtube
and they're like don't but they owe me
they owe you nothing
it's been lovely that they've given me
so much money and so much fame
i've moved on if i again i see people
who are trying and they make a patreon
and they make a twitch and they're like
again if that's what you want to do if
you like your read like i'm coaching you
right now and if you're a youtuber
listening to this if you want to be on
youtube and you like your reason for
being on youtube
yay focus on that but if you're just
chasing something that's really not
there
and you are constantly looking for an
external solution to an internal problem
there's not enough likes or money in the
world that's going to solve this
and youtube does give you that quick
dopamine but it is like putting a
band-aid on what you need to solve
yeah okay we're going to take a quick
break and let that
settle in because oh that's hitting me
on all the good spots okay we'll be
right back with more not too deep and
michael buckley just
preaching some truth
no not too deep what's grace's
okay uh michael in in line with like
you giving up youtube uh you've also
given up
alcohol real housewives and fast food
what
what which of those three alcohol real
housewives or
fast food was the most difficult to give
up probably real housewives because
it's on hulu every season and it's good
to fall asleep too
so it's funny because like fast food
took
a couple tries alcohol was actually easy
but if i had to rank them
and also i'm a lovely person and i wish
to see the best in you
so sonia morgan ramona singer dorinda i
wish to see the best in you
but you're not giving me much these days
so it's taken me it's been a conscious
uncoupling of the real housewives
yeah i know because one of my favorite
things is watching you
uh watch the real housewives but and i'm
also a major fan but i share the same
like discouragement that their character
arcs melissa and i were literally just
talking about this before we started the
podcast
that they were like this and now they're
just slowly going down and it's hard to
watch
that happen and there's nothing
aspirational so when bethany's on
there's
aspiration and she's the good comedic
peanut gallery
but left to their own devices dorinda
ramon estonia being
shit-faced at 60 years old i'm not that
compelled to watch this
you know i agree a hundred a hundred
percent
um so what are you watching now i'm not
good at tv
i'm not really like i do my best to
watch a program because i want to do
instagrams and i want to know what's
going on in the world
but then i end up looking and i just put
on golden girls designing women
or sex in the city or something i've
seen a lot
but i will say i love i'm watching on
disney plus
i loved encore where they're in their
musicals and they go back
and redo them cast of 92 would love to
do guys and dolls
danger high school middletown
connecticut sign me up but i also love
i'm watching a docu-series on the making
of frozen two
and i try every episode so that's fun
okay okay um okay so you now
live in colorado and you live with your
twin sister
and her children and uh with that
can you explain to people who might not
know what a gunkle is
a gunko is a homosexual uncle so yes
do you describe yourself okay
and i live in a basement it's amazing i
always love telling that story too i
went from living in two four bedroom
homes with
addicts and um basements and now i mean
and now i live in a basement
people would see me and be like it's not
going well i'm like there's nowhere i'd
rather be
i used to wander around my home like
what am i doing
and now now that i'm here my old brain
is always looking at homes like i should
go live in an old four bedroom home i'm
like i want to live in a one-bedroom
condo or a tiny house
for the rest of my life i don't i don't
want all that [ __ ] you know
no that's so great it feels like you've
definitely simplified your life
from every aspect these are the only
books i have in the world
the other day i got rid of my last three
knickknacks when i moved here three
years ago
i kept three knickknacks of all of my
knickknacks and i thought i love bees
they still bring me joy marie condo
but then i looked at them the other day
i'm like i don't wish to be a person
with any knickknacks
i had expensive coffee table books i
don't wish to be a person with any of
this [ __ ]
so again i have nothing i have the
clothes on my back a computer
and just i love it i love that i watched
the documentary on minimalism
and the guy said love people use things
and i realized like alcohol
the moment i quit alcohol i started
shopping more so again talking about
looking for an external solution
there wasn't going to be enough throw
pillows in the world of home goods
so it's like i definitely was like yeah
i buy stuff and now i'm like i want
nothing
wow i mean except for your j crew we
have to
i love yes not sponsored
i that blows my mind that of all the
sponsorships that could be still
floating in your ether that one has to
come through soon
oh my god um okay
what seems to be the most common
you're working with a lot of clients in
life coaching is there one
common issue that is the most prevalent
either through clients or through like
messages that you get on instagram
or twitter or anything is it is there
one like overarching theme that people
seem to come to you about so here's the
funny thing when you hire a life coach
you fill out a form and you generally
show up and you have things that you
want coaching on and then the more you
coach and you learn you realize that
again
you're the problem it's not your mother
it's not your career
and a lot of times it is just your
self-love it is your self-worth it's
like it's amazing that
if i don't feel loved and worthy and
give myself that every day
i'm constantly looking for it from a new
boyfriend or a new career
or a bigger house and so again i will
coach you on what you come for
but then ultimately you realize oh it's
a little bit more of just i need to like
and love and appreciate myself more on a
daily basis
so yeah so a lot of people come for
coaching and then they realize
oh it's me and i just need to be nicer
to myself on a daily basis
it's always been me
okay if you could design your own float
for a pride parade
and there was the budget was no option
what would it look like for you
it would look like christine baranski
julie walters
and amanda seyfried in the scene from
mamma mia too here we go again
angel eyes so it would be greek island
and they would be in their caftans and
it would look like the scene
go on youtube right now and type it in
angel eyes mamma mia here we go again
that's all i want in the world oh i love
it
uh so i mean you're talking about before
like you went from two big homes to a
basement
in your sister's house your life
feels like it's like ripe for a movie
and if it was made into one who would
play you
if obviously not for yourself oh my god
somebody gay somebody very gay
i mean i would love to say someone hot
like bradley cooper but it would
probably be some like nerdy
bald guy um ed harris
i don't know i don't know i don't know
okay
i would play me i was doing a reading
the other day of a movie on like a zoom
call because you know it's 20 20 and
that's what we're doing
and they said have you seen the movie
and i said no don't worry i'm just gonna
do valerie cherish from the comeback
doing this role
that's the performance you're gonna get
so yeah
good luck directing me yeah that's uh i
want you to know
upfront yeah we can collaborate but i
already know what my part is
this is my role um
okay do you think you actually match
well with your astrological sign
oh my god i'm a gemini i have a gemini
tattoo
i am a twin so it's funny because gemini
is twin
i think i have a mug and it says witty
um
optimistic intelligent and adaptable so
yes if you google
gemini i definitely bit the mold of that
i love that
there is a duality i just made a sign
because that means twin for those
watching at home i'm signing twin
or no that's toilet this is twit
i fixed up my tees this is toilet
this is twin but getting a twin
um you know it's a bit of like a gemini
tends to have a split personality but i
do actually have a twin sister
but in terms of the split personality
there is a warmth and a coldness to me
and i love that i used to hate it
because i am so warm and lovely
the moment i'd get cold i would be like
oh god now i love when i'm cold
so again i love and that's the thing
about life coaching
i always say i love all the terrible
things about myself i'm not
i'm not conditionally i oh i love me
when i'm rich and when i'm thin and when
i'm in love
i love me when i'm horrible i'm a human
being i love all the terrible things
about myself
oh that's lovely uh well in terms of
like in coaching you're obviously giving
so many
pieces of advice who do you go to for
advice
so that's interesting because i have a
lot of like coaches and mentors and
stuff
and i tried i've been through so many
training programs that i feel like right
now i'm not following anybody like that
because yeah
i've been solidifying my voice as a
coach versus when you start coaching and
you do a program you kind of end up
sounding like that person
so if you go to a tony robbins course
you might just start oh he sounds like
tony robbins
so or oh you watch a lot of like brene
brown and now you're talking about
vulnerability and all that
so i did a lot of coach training five
years ago four years ago three years ago
and now i'm always just kind of like
just just listening and learning and
reading positive psychology
i also love re-reading books so like i'm
re-reading
the seven highly habits of effective
people i love
this book and this is a book i read
years ago but it didn't hit me right
because my brain wasn't ready for it
so i love reading books five years later
10 years later two years later
so i'm always reading i'm always doing
online courses i use
coursera or udemy and i'm always taking
courses in positive psychology or
neuro-linguistics
or philosophy so it's funny how during
covent
all my free time is just spent reading
and doing online courses so that's what
i'm doing a lot of
cool what um what's i know you're into
office supplies too
is there any what's your major
recommendations for those that are
building their minimalist home office
when i was a child grace helping all i
wanted to do was go to my
father dennis buckley's office and raid
the filing cabinet of supplies and i
couldn't wait for the day when i had my
own stapler
and tape dispenser like this was it
i wanted these like they were toys
now today my favorite office supplies
are
having a stand for my phone you can get
an eight pack on the amazon i would
never want my phone to not be in the
stand
and i love a giant post test so i've got
giant post-its and all these beautiful
colors
and this is what i use for like my
vision board affirmation wall
so i've got all my goals i've got all my
best feelings i've got all of my mantras
so i love
a giant post-it which is a good visual
cue
of all the things i want to be thinking
and feeling and achieving all day
that's wonderful and uh like just a i
love a
big size anything it's great i mean
and we'll skip over that
okay let's talk about tattoos so
you have how many tattoos do you have at
this current moment
28. 28. and
how when was when did you get your first
tattoo
so exactly four years ago
yesterday i got a youtube play button i
think i was drunk it's 10 yes it's
deformed it doesn't look like a play
button
for a first tattoo like you should get a
tattoo here
i got it right on the floppy party
and so it's always being deported
hideous
but i love it i love it i i love it
again i love
and i love it all as a bigger picture if
i just had that i'd be like oh god
but because i've got 28 i see the bigger
picture of it all
and for me i love tattoos represent an
evolution of
i if you watch videos of me back in the
day i used to make fun of tattoos
especially for like actresses i'd be
like you should be a blank canvas
i know i want to see rachel barry not
leah michelle's hideous green
tattoo and then suddenly here i am years
later
and i love tattoos and for me i love
because it's decisive
i made a decision to do something and i
you know i just i love my ability to be
decisive and sell all my possessions or
change careers or get a tattoo and a
tattoo is permission to see myself
differently if i see an old video i'd be
like
i would never have a tattoo and now i
see me i'm like of course i'm michael
buckley i'm the type of person who
easily and often gets tattoos
what's the next one do you have any more
in mind like when it was appropriate
again and not like an ugly mean dragon
but a cartoon fun dragon
because like my tattoos are pretty but a
dragon represents
confidence a dragon doesn't second guess
itself
a dragon doesn't not worry about how
it's showing up in the world so again
if i'm gonna have a spirit animal i'm
not gonna have some gay unicorn i'm
gonna have a goddamn dragon
who wants to show up powerfully and
decisive and amazing so i want a dragon
i want something jesusy because i'm very
into god so i'd like to get some crosses
or something but every time i google
jesus the tattoos they're always
weird-looking
so i'd like some sort of something
religious and spiritual and lovely
i mean that also feels like something
you could uh task
out to your followers to submit some uh
i'd love a
cross and a dragon and you know anything
something cool
uh okay because so you wrote a book in
2017 called help my kid wants to be a
youtuber
right yes and this was obviously for
parents of children that want to be
youtubers so this was my career
transition because it's interesting
because
the coach i was working with on that i
was coaching her son
on youtube and she's very successful she
lives in a castle she probably makes 20
million dollars a year coaching
and so in her brain she thought
but you should be a life coach or a
creative coach for youtube
that's your 100k a month business and so
at the time i wanted to get out of
youtube and i wanted to use my skills
differently
so like that was an interesting in like
that was an attempt at a career
between youtube and life coaching the
problem is i couldn't care less about
youtube
i really didn't want to be coaching
children so i'm so glad i
did that because that segwayed me from
youtube
to coaching and that was my in between
coaching which i was
i enjoyed it i charged money for it it
was okay
but it wasn't my sweet spot so that i'm
really grateful for that chapter but
that was like an in-between chapter
ah and so is this book still available
for people please don't buy it
okay i will make money if you buy it but
it's basically a client conversion book
meaning you read the book
and then you want to work with me and
i'll get an email saying
you read the book can you work with me
and i'll say nope
[Laughter]
but thank you for trying to plug my book
got it got it got it
um okay i know that you've been you're
you're
you promote or not promote you you've
broadcast that you've been celibate for
a while
uh but what is that i know i mean
kudos you've really minimalized your
life in so many ways
so much honestly not being on grindr or
tinder or scruff or
i don't ever want to be on an app again
yeah
i don't want to interact with someone
like that
i'm an outgoing person if i wish to meet
somebody for dating or sex i know how to
go out and do it the old-fashioned way
right um and i love not having sex
because i am very sex positive i went
from being monogamously married for 13
years
and then i thought i've been missing out
so the next thing you know it's group
sex it's orgies it's anybody can have
sex because we're all i'm prepping
and then suddenly you were like is this
what i want so again i went so far from
being monogamously married to being
giant [ __ ]
i wanted to figure out how to land
somewhere in the middle
and so there's something about like
um i love not having sex just as much as
i loved having tons of sex
and i think i'm gonna be celibate for at
least a year and i don't even think i'm
gonna consider dating again until i'm
like 50.
i think i'm in a deeply committed
relationship with myself i love my
relationship with god
i think who i am in the world needs to
be single
i think my best value to the world i
can't imagine having someone sitting
there over there be like you're my
partner
i think i'm the greatest love of my life
and so much of my life has been boys and
men
and i love i'm not on the market i'm not
available
if i meet the most spectacular man and
he wishes to fall in love with me
i'm not going to begrudge him the
pleasure but i'm certainly
not out there you know but i am amazing
and i'm just not going to date someone
to spend time with like if you're
amazing and wish to tap in
slide into my dms but it's probably a no
i think that's so great i mean yeah
because you have so much momentum going
you don't need any anchors holding
your back boyfriend for four years in
college i was married for 13 years i
know what great love and partnership
feels like and i believe there's plenty
of that
i believe when i'm 50 or 60 i'll pick
another life partner and say let's spend
from now until death together
but i think 20s and 30s was for other
people 40s are all for me man so i'm 45
and i've been single and it's been
working and it's been delightful
good for you good for you that's another
life choice like i don't want you like
that
we're brainwashed you should have a
beautiful big home and two kids
and you should want to be famous and you
should want who wouldn't want a life
partner
and here's the other thing about being
single and i hope people listen and hear
this
for years i talked the talk but i didn't
walk the walk
because i acted like i liked being
single i was like no this is fun
but in the back of my brain i always
thought but it would be nice to have
somebody
and this is the first time in my life
for the last two or three years that i'm
like
i'm good man yeah i'm good like i
really enjoy being single and i love
thinking single and behaving single
and my life is so full of love and so
can
i've never felt so connected with myself
or my greater life purpose
and sometimes when you're in a
relationship that can distract you from
your own needs and your greater life
purpose because you're so busy
trying to be a partner and a spouse and
that's lovely and i don't regret you
that pleasure
but i'm here to tell you it's not the
end all beyond
yeah totally and uh i mean that's
beautiful
and a massive uh
uh challenge for anyone that wants to
attempt to slide into a dm
of someone that's just so full of love
for themselves
i don't like being with yourself there's
not enough compliments or steps
or relationship quality time that's
going to give that to you so i am 100
good to go in love unconditionally with
myself and someday
if i meet someone who also is then maybe
we will make a great partner
but i am again 100 whole and enjoying
life
so yeah good for you okay on that note
we're gonna take one last break when we
get back
i have a bunch of really fun twitter
questions for you so i'll be right back
with more not too deep
[Music]
okay we're back in and i'm gonna ask you
before we get into these twitter
questions
the two questions i ask every single
guest that is on the podcast
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most want to throw cold spaghetti at
oh my god i mean right now it's gotta be
donald trump
yeah the problem is he'd enjoy it he
probably paid me to piss on him and
throw spaghetti on
but yeah it's got to be donald trump
love yeah praying for you
hoping you turn it around someday i hope
i mean for all of our sake
yes okay the other question i ask every
single guest
uh is to tell us your worst pants
[ __ ] story
or close call but you can only use
three words or three small phrases to
describe it so for instance mine
is college jogging front lawn
i'm gay happens
honestly no offense but if you're a
homosexual and you've had things in your
butt somebody
just shake yourself well welcome
welcome to being a homosexual because
you prep for sex and then suddenly
i i love that this episode has advice on
all levels for all different things
yeah i remember being a young homosexual
and getting ready for sex and then being
like oh i'm not
[Laughter]
the done watching no oh
i shouldn't have left the house yet oh i
love it
keep wipes on your dashboard
solid tip solid tip okay let's get into
these twitter questions
the first one um someone had about seven
different questions but i'll just pick
one from
uh all of these and it is
uh how do you spur yourself into action
oh that's a really good question so i
mean i'm i
really try and increase and improve my
internal motivation
and it's interesting because a lot of
times really our thoughts are creating
our feelings creating our actions so if
i'm not in action
i'm always seeking to understand why i'm
not
because if i just jump into action i'm
not really understanding why i'm not
taking action
so for me if i'm not taking action i'm
thinking what the hell am i feeling what
the hell am i thinking
and then i try and create a thought that
will inspire me
because i create deliberate inspiration
every day i'm not waiting around to feel
motivated and inspired so i'm using my
brain
so again use your brain to create
deliberate intentional motivation every
day yay yeah and i think
you emphasize this a lot in your
instagram story it's about writing [ __ ]
down
every day every day and i think it
sounds so simple but i think it's so
impactful
to actually do the physicality of
writing something down because like you
say
the amount of thoughts that we have
going through our brains unmanaged is
like
infinite so you really have to kind of
lasso them in a little bit
wrangle them in and see what happens
from there so much goes wrong every day
if you're driving to work i'm gonna be
in a good mood then you get an email
then you have a weird co-exchange and
then it's like so that even right now
today i'm showing up joyful
understanding appreciative and
encouraging i've picked my feelings for
the day
i know how i'm gonna show up today i'm
not waiting for the day to show up to me
so again i always i always have
deliberate mindset i know how this
podcast is gonna go
i'm not waiting for it to be over to
decide that was fun grace
i came in excited i came in open heart
and i came in
loving you so much so i know this is
gonna be fun
i i feel like they should redo like the
opening scene in clueless where she's
like picking out her outfit on the
computer with just like feelings
that describes about her thoughts and
her feelings yes exactly
that's amazing okay someone says
um with your new attitude to life what
advice would you give young michael
what advice would i give what young
michael your younger sister oh my god
i mean i would part of me wouldn't want
to give him any advice because i'd want
him to go through every i would hate for
him to miss any of the growth
opportunities
i am 45 years old i know better and i do
better
so i really i look back at 30 year old
20 year old with a compassionate
lens so i mean i might just say to him
you're going to end up exactly where you
need to be
love yourself unconditionally every step
of the way
regardless of yourself so yes because
there's been times in my life when i've
really beat myself up and i've really
suffered at the expense of myself
and i'm glad that i did that but i'm
glad i'm on the other side of it
then i might have done it at 50 or 60.
so again i wouldn't want
young michael to know anything he's he's
amazing i love him
a lot of people are asking kind of the
same question how do you remain
so positive you just radiate joyful
vibes i want to do that too
someone says the optimism this man has
needs to be bottled and sold at j crew
how can he be so positive in this world
yeah so i always think what's the
alternative like again
i can be really negative my brain knows
what side again the world is giving me
donald trump and coveted racism so i can
easily go down that rabbit hole
so again even on my poster today i'm
reminding myself to show up joyful
i get to do this i don't have to do
anything that's one of my simple shifts
i always say to clients i have to pick
up my kids i have to do this expense
report you do not have to pick up your
kids you get
it is a luxury many women abandon their
children many people do not do their
jobs and get fired
everything i do is optional my life i
have a personal mission statement i live
in line with every day
so again i do choose positive emotions
over and over but i'm also
really good at allowing and processing
my negative emotions
and i'm also good at neutralizing things
so i mean that's something like when you
have a terrible life event you don't
need to turn it into a positive
you at least need to neutralize it or
like i'm doing right now seeing the
growth opportunity yes there's covet yes
there's racism
uh yes there's donald trump in office
i'm not waiting for that to go away for
me to feel better i'm responsible for my
emotions every day
that's great and would you say that it's
really practicing over time to be able
to do that on such an easier
like autopilot type of way yeah and it's
definitely writing it down because i
read all the books i read you're the
secret i read you're a badass
i believe all that [ __ ] and it's all
helpful but if you're just
reading that book then you're just a
consumer of self-help
you need to take the book or take the
podcast and write the [ __ ] down if i
wasn't doing this every day
it wouldn't be sticking so when i first
started doing this there was plenty of
wiggle room and even as
as not far back as 2018 i wasn't writing
every day i was still having hit or miss
months emotionally financially
spiritually
and then the more i kept doing the work
like i look at
this journal this is my journal from
and it's a vidcon journal thank you hank
and john green last time i've ever been
and we'll probably go to vidcon
maybe the 20-year anniversary this is
september 2019 to april of this year
this is the best work i've ever done on
myself
this is the stuff i always look back on
i'm like oh
my god i've solved so many things
i've coached myself through so many
things i've picked power and people's
message me and say how do i journal if
you're not going to just write down
journaling like oh dear diary give
yourself an amazing question how can i
like and love myself a little bit more
today
how can i be an example of what is
possible today how can i live in line
more with my purpose today
how can i be a more loving mother
co-worker spouse today
give your brain some direction if you
ask yourself an amazing question you
will come up with an amazing answer so
that's my journaling tip if you're
watching like what is journaling
no i think that's great you need a
writing prompt you need something to
kind of
launch you into it um this is my
question
with all of this with all this work that
you're doing would you ever
do like a tony robbins type of like
convention tour live show situation
yes i mean i think that's in my future
i'm so enjoying where i'm at right now
and i'm making sure i'm doing that
because as a youtuber i never enjoyed
where i was at
i was always looking backwards to when
it was going well
or in the future so i never really
savored it like if i look back at my
peak youtube years i
never really enjoyed them i was always
either thinking this is gonna go away
tomorrow
or whatever so now i'm so enjoying the
work i'm doing that i don't want to
lose sight of it so again that is a goal
i would love to do that
i would love to you know have a podcast
have a live motivational speaking tour
and i do see that in my future yes cool
but i'm very much enjoying today
that's very exciting um
someone wants to know what do you miss
most about youtube
um i want us to i don't i mean i miss
seeing you
more because like i'd see you at event i
mean i miss i miss the friendships and
the connections
i don't i'm not someone though who
missed because i
here's the thing too when i was just
this is what i was just speaking to
i'm so present focused all i'm thinking
about right now
is i'm so glad i get to spend a couple
minutes with grace
so i let myself look into the future and
i have an eye on that but i'm so present
focused
so i just don't go backwards very much
you said what do you miss about high
school
doing the musicals what do you miss
about youtube the easy money
yeah the easy money like it was very
easy to get money thrown i know but i
don't
i miss i don't miss things i'm just so
enjoying life i'm just seeing you
and you know some of my youtube friends
more often that i used to like see you
twice a year
so i miss that but i love you know being
friends on instagram and twitter to keep
up with you
you know totally totally i think that's
great because there is like
the uh there's a tendency like kind of
what you mentioned before
if you start indulging in missing
something you start like romanticizing
this thing that might not have been the
way that it actually was
for you uh which is not necessarily the
healthiest thing
speaking of not healthy which housewives
franchise was the most difficult to give
up
oh my gosh well i step so i stayed with
new york the longest because i am from
connecticut and massachusetts and spend
lots of time in new york city
so in terms of me relating to a certain
type of woman like i'm like i get these
women
like i watch oh see i'm like i don't get
it
i don't get it i don't get it i love
beverly hills i've clung to a little bit
too because i do like eric and jane
and i do i like kyle every other season
like kyle's fine and then she's not
so again it's interesting so i've i've
hung in with new york
and beverly hills the longest oc got
i kept with ocd and then kelly was mean
and vicki and tamara were mean and
yelling and
it just again that's where new york is
right now new york new york has hit a
wall
and then yeah luanne isn't a strong
enough bethany to be the central figure
i was hoping luanne would be the central
figure she's not strong enough to be the
central figure
yeah i agree i agree a hundred percent i
feel like you should be
involved in the casting of potential new
seasons andy
called me i would have helped but i'd
love to put together an
aspirational group of women to root for
yes yes i agree yeah um okay someone's
know what do you miss the most about the
east coast
i miss being close to broadway i mean i
love going to new york and seeing two or
three shows a week
i missed being close to cape cod and
being part of the ocean like
colorado is beautiful but there is no
ocean so we've got the mountains we've
got beautiful weather
but i do you know in 10 years i'm sure
i'll be living like halftime on cape cod
in halftime somewhere else
but uh yeah i do miss the ocean and i do
miss the broadway
and i also miss again i'm very fast
talking fast walking people here are
slumber
that's not an insult but you know i i'm
used to a new york person who walks fast
talk fast thinks that
and so i'm very much an east coast
person
well i'm excited for you to be uh to
share the
the wealth of yourself with the east
coast eventually
uh okay last question before we wrap up
and i could talk to you for three more
hours very easy i love you so much thank
you so much
it's been so lovely oh i agree okay uh
stephanie says your life has changed
pretty drastically since the start of
your youtube career
what does your average day look like now
so i wake up every day around 7 30. i
let the dog out i put the coffee on
i come downstairs i get dressed in my
uniform of j
crew sweater tech pants and i wear the
same i get dressed
every day and then i work on for this
wonderful senior living
company arrow senior living shout out
and i am i am their coach i do personal
development and leadership
and i'm on calls for about seven or
eight hours a day
with their leadership team and so if
that's such a wonderful story of someone
who
my amanda who hired me as her life coach
and then said i have this company
and it became four people nine people
everybody
and so that is i do take one-on-one
clients occasionally
but most of my day is with arrow senior
living so if you're looking for a job
it's an amazing company to work for and
you've got access to a life coach
there you go that's a good
as grace knows my evenings were playing
recreational soccer four days a week
so it is my life is everybody listening
i'm
45 years old 41 year old me does not
recognize
me i have a different career i'm full of
tattoos
i play flag football and recreational
indoor and outdoor soccer
and i again i love that i do
if i was still living in connecticut
making youtube videos that
i don't know i don't know how much
longer that would happen
but again no wonder i was drinking so
much because i could barely manage that
and now i know in five or ten years if
it's time to do something else again
i bring it on man like it's not great
life is not
linear always be willing and open to
evolve into new and amazing versions of
yourself spiritually emotionally
financially like
that otherwise what the hell man from
now until death who do you want to be
you get to decide every day
yes yes i love that also
uh if you guys really want to see what
michael's life is like
just follow his instagram story he is
very candid
very uh consistently posting over there
i love it
literally the reason that i have any
following on instagram story is because
grace or elliott or mamrie or someone
once a year says hey check out buck then
i get a couple hundred followers so
thank you yes on
instagram story hey michael buckley i'm
on there all day
and if you are interested in coaching i
have my highlights tab
coaching nine coaching seven coaching
six so go there and listen and learn and
start writing some stuff down great
michael this has been so wonderful as
always you'll have to come back in the
future and do a whole part two
and we'll just get more into all of it
um because i think it's all
extremely relevant for a lot of people
right now
um but before we go usually when we do
these uh
podcasts in person we have a
personalized fortune cookie from us to
our guest who's made time
but because of this way we have a
virtual fortune cookie so feel free to
go
open that little email right now i have
a fortune cookie and it says
we would like to remind everyone that
geminis are not
two-faced they simply see every side
geminis are not easily distracted they
just want to try
everything and most definitely not nosy
they just want the whole story i love
that fortune
that's pretty spot on thank you
michael where can people like you said
they follow you on instagram and your
stories
yeah you i have a website hey michael
buckley.com
i keep a blog over there i do maintain a
pretty active instagram story so if you
look at my instagram and it doesn't seem
like i post a lot
i am on instagram story all day just
trying to add joy and possibility to the
world
and i love that and that does that
satisfies my desire to create
content without having to make a youtube
video and edit it and promote it and
care if people see it
so i do have thousands of people
watching and engaging with me
and that gives me a little joy that
gives me love lovely joy
and gives me a relationship with people
who did they thought fondly of what they
bought 10 years ago and they would like
to keep up with me in some way
and so instagram story is my way of
doing that so it'd be it would be lovely
to see you over there
i love it thank you again for making
today thank you grace i love you i adore
you i'm so proud of you i can't wait to
see what your next chapter in your life
is going to be
is comment uh and make sure you guys go
follow michael he's nothing but
joy radiating constantly and it is just
so
lovely with all the everything that's
happening
uh we'll see you guys next time on
another episode of not too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
with christ
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music